life is good for him right now certainly
is especially on the football front as
LSU Tigers are ranked number one getting
set to take on Oklahoma in a national
semifinal and his Los Angeles Rams with
him anchoring that offensive line that's
been changed due to injury pretty much
all around him the Rams have won three
of four and look just like the team last
year that made the Super Bowl and the
last month he is Andrew Whitworth good
to see you sir good to see you rich
preciate so you know and it's funny to
Brockman and I when we saw you back in
our green room we see these purple and
gold shoes and and you and you said LSU
right I'll see you around
and then you respond to me one I said in
the lake show about my caliber on and
the Lakers man that's why I warm you
know what a purple and gold you know
we're on top right now 21 and three in
the NBA and undefeated in college
football man and now and now the Rams as
well let's let's start obviously with
with the Rams here first what has
changed in the last month that you can
put your finger on for every what I
think really just the efficiency
throughout our team you know if it's if
it's really the young guys if it's the
guys around those young guys playing
playing better it's you know all of us
at the same time finding a way to be
better version of ourselves be able to
go out every single week play at a high
level and have that expectation you know
not just hope it happens but they expect
it to happen and anytime you you're
dealing with youth and replace and
injured guys there's gonna be a hole
there there's gonna be a hey you know
what developing trust and understanding
one another talking about the line in
general I mean really just the offense
in general I mean you gotta think of
everything from a run play to a pass
play the backs you know how you've
always done it for them in the past
these young guys got to learn how to do
that and the backs guy learn how to
trust them and the quarterbacks gotta
learn how to trust the line and all
those things so it's it's really about
coming together as a group and being
able to trust one another go out to
expect to play well and know that you
know what I don't need to worry about
who's doing their job I expect that
everybody is and let's go out and be
confident play well how have you taken
on a leadership role on this with all
those young guys on that line Andrew
well I you know it's one of those things
I feel like to me how I do things and
how I hope to that those guys would
really also voice that I would do it is
that I feel like I'm that way every
single day that I'm in the office and
and
work regardless of the situation and so
this year even more importantly I think
it's one of those things where I always
say this young guys you know to me when
you come in the NFL your first couple of
years it's about learning how to play
good football you know then all of a
sudden you get a contract and it's about
living up to expectations of playing
good football and then it's how do you
take the next step how do you become a
leader how do you become a guy who you
know not only do you need to play well
but you make guys around you play well
there's a different progression so for
me I've always taken that to heart that
it's really about what more can I do
other than just the football side of
going out and doing my job I've got to
be able to affect everyone to help us
all do our job and so for me really it's
it's every single day with these young
guys talking about the things that will
help them be good football players today
tomorrow and in the future and making
sure that I don't ever let anything slip
anything slide and you know what I'm
just constantly there for them to ask
questions and then also to push them to
be the best thing best players they can
be and for me it's been an awesome
challenge it's fun to see that youth
those young guys getting their first
opportunity ever sure the excitement
that's that's there for them every week
you know almost the fawn of oh my gosh
I'm playing Cleo Mack or oh my goodness
I'm playing Chandler Jones you know
these guys two years ago they're
watching these guys on TV you know and
so it's uh it's fun to see their faces
and their excitement it almost gives me
a renewed spirit doing what I do as well
I again year 14 that that is amazing to
hear as fans and members of the media
Andrew Whitworth here in the Rich Eisen
show hearing somebody who's been in it
as long as you have or anybody who is a
veteran say hey you just got to play
better you just got to trust people
we're we're looking for a clique moment
we're looking for okay that play that
moment that game was there one can you
identify one I really think for us
honestly if you look at it really for
further just talking about our line and
really the injuries we've had and having
new guys have to step in and play you
know you really look at coming out of
the Pittsburgh game with all those
injuries happening you walk into the
week and say alright you know here we go
we're about to play the Bears and a
great defense and a bunch of really
special defensive linemen over there and
you say alright we're going in it with
guys who've played a whopping you know
me and Austin Blythe have play these
other guys
of you know really one of them started a
football game before and so three guys
one start you know we knew it'd be a
challenge but there was almost just like
an energy and and a you know what let's
just go take our shot see what happens
let's all go out be physical all three
of them were big physical athletic young
kids who have Bright Futures and it's
like man look just go be aggressive go
go out and just you know what play like
it's like it's your first time playing
high school football play with the
energy with passion and let's see where
the chips fall you know and just be
aggressive and those guys did it and and
obviously there's good and bad in the
game but you go man okay like these guys
can do I like to go out on this stage
and perform the way they did all right
and then the next weekend it's Baltimore
obviously it's a landslide game that you
know they they really had a tremendous
game against us but really up front guys
showed some progress there was things
that guys were doing better you're just
watching them specifically and then you
know the next week you come out and it's
like all right against Arizona they have
a great performance and it's like okay
these guys are getting better and better
every week and then this week continue
to show the same thing so I think that's
what made us excited is that they really
kind of just as a group we put our feet
in the ground and said hey let's just go
out and play with energy and passion and
see what happens and every week it's
gotten a step better and that's what
really makes you feel good about their
group and and happy for some young guys
get an opportunity and we're seeing
Gurley the og show up yeah it doesn't
mean when he when he when he stiff arms
Trey flowers like that what is it like
for the team just a single moment like
that yeah I think you know for a running
back to me that's one of those
opportunities it's it's no different
than sack fumble for a Russia or it's
it's no different than a huge over the
over-the-top catch for a receiver for
his position you know that opportunity
of just saying you know what I won't be
tackled
I think the inspir inspiration really
that you're lying gets that your offense
gets and goes man that you know that
guys on our team and and and and there's
why we all love him so much is that he
has those moments and games were just
like man he just refuses to be tackled
and and does something explosive like
that to really sill a football game for
us
III this year I've always had respect
for Todd Gurley I've always thought Todd
Gurley was a tremendous player and
really a just a great kid in general
since I met him
this season I've grown just at really
truly such a love for him and in the
human being he is why why huh you know
really just you look at everything that
happened all the media speculation all
the things that pointed to him all
offseason long and really not a lot of
it positive you know and the way he's
dealt with it the way the leader he's
been in our huddle the leader he's been
in our locker room every single day with
his passion and pushing guys to play
better and to respond and never once
complained and ever once saying I
deserve the ball more I deserve this
opportunity or these things it's always
just been about our team and to me a guy
like that that's a tremendous player he
is to carry himself the way he's carried
himself this season man I'll never
forget it and I'll always have the
utmost respect for him for it left
tackle Andrew Whitworth in season 14
four-time Pro Bowler right here on the
Rich Eisen show continuing on with
Gurley he's getting the rock more since
you were talking about that Bears game
he's getting it more he's getting those
touches he's damn near on a couple games
30 touches which is a very high
watermark for any running back and
certainly for him when asked where this
came from
why now Shaun McVeigh said it's me not
being an idiot
now I've never heard anybody call Shaun
McVeigh an idiot or anything remotely
close to that is it really just him or
is there something else Andrew I think
it goes to what I said earlier it's that
trust factor right that all of us really
I mean we didn't run it well early in
the year and not because of Todd
necessarily just because we weren't
executing run plays very well and so we
got forced to throw it and then we also
had some games we were down and we all
of a sudden had to throw it a bunch and
so you get in those scenarios and you
start going alright well you know what
let's make sure we're not losing our
identity a little bit of what it is that
we do well and trying to find the trust
of hey we got a young group of guys
we're trying to figure out all how to
block things the way we want them done
and all those type things and I think
really comes back to all right you know
what you got a young line but now
they've shown they can do these things
just trust them let's give Todd the ball
and let him be the guy he's always been
for us and that's really what it's come
down to and I think that's more what
he's saying is that it's really hey
let's trust what we got let's trust who
and let's just go out and play that
style of football and let the chips fall
how they will and I think that we've
seen that that that really is who we are
and how we play best what does it mean
to be playing in Dallas late-afternoon
whole country will be tuning in your
team's one three or four we all know
what's going on in Dallas what what what
does this mean do you think this game
this weekend
I think it means a lot I mean I look at
it too it's it's funny that it's a you
know a little bit of a symbolic game for
us too because it's it's the game that
in 17 you know really people said we put
ourselves on the map you know when we
had a loss to Seattle at home and people
were trying to figure out who Jared golf
was who Sean McVeigh was it's our first
year all together we go on the road
against the Dallas team that at that
time you know people had a lot of
expectation for that season and get down
early in the game and find a way to come
back and have this huge win on the road
the first time really as a team like
that and and I can never forget it was
really that moment that season that
things took off for us and we lost who
we were in the style of football we were
gonna play that season I think it's
something that funny to go back there in
this moment here we are and we got an
opportunity to finish this thing the
right way with three weeks to go and be
the team who we think we are to have an
opportunity to go prove it again on a
national stage man I mean you you look
for ops like this and so we're just
excited I pretty much know the answer
but I'll follow up what is the team you
think you are you know what I think
we're explosive physical football team
and you really look at last year I
thought that's how we ended our season
is that the last three weeks of the
season we really went to more of an of
really being a run heavy kind of
physical football team with our play
actions and all the things we like to do
off of it and we carried that on into
the playoffs and that's who we were in
the playoffs as well and you know what
playing aggressive and in tenacious on
defense and you know what I think that
it's one of those things that that's who
we were in in last season and going into
the playoffs and I think we're excited
about that's the football team we look
like with this opportunity and
unfortunately we put ourselves in a
situation where we don't control our
destiny but what we do control is how we
finish these three weeks and if somebody
gives us an opportunity we'll be excited
Andrew Whitworth here on the Rich Eisen
show season 14
in the NFL and you've seen a lot you've
you've been there you've done that
you've been around so long that you if
I'm not mistaken we're just in year two
the last time the Patriots were involved
in a situation where we're wondering if
they were training camera on the
sidelines to the for something other
than a proper purpose and I'm done
dancing around the subject what do you
think about this whole subject matter
you know I think it's tough I mean
obviously it's one of those that's gonna
send up everybody's alerts across the
league I mean obviously you know it's
one of those things when you keep being
involved in a topic or something and it
centers around seems to be one team it
it makes it tough because it's one of
those things where you go yeah it sounds
like it's a harmless situation but you
know what why is it always this team
that's involved in these harmless
situations you know and those kind of
things something I think that's one of
the things that has players across the
league in general I think that's really
the thought most guys have just because
it's tough that it's always seems to be
them involved in something like this and
I know it also it's just it's just funny
I mean the whole situation like we're
filming in advance scouting documentary
or something I don't know well I means
for a local it's for their own
television show that and behind the
scenes up shooting behind the scenes
footage or of people doing their job for
the Patriots I mean the your your
broadcasting Department is here training
two cameras on us right now you know or
not you know what I didn't get a
heads-up arm and again we were genuinely
concerned that they're shooting at least
eight minutes of behind-the-scenes
footage that might reveal Britch eyes
and show secrets for other shows to try
and come at us but we're understand that
people come at the king you understand
but how do you think this is gonna play
in locker rooms across the across the
NFL do you think like I said I think it
creates a lot of you know just skips
isn't I mean oh my god just you know
it's like hey why is it always seem to
be that they're involved in something
but at the end of the day sounds like
it's something that's pretty harmless
but it's just you know it's also also
very strange that you're just filming
the Bingle sideline I don't know but how
paranoid how paranoid your teams in the
NFL I mean about signs and I think well
I think in particular when it comes to
them I mean a lotta man oh every time
you play them or
or have gone there when I was in
Cincinnati it was always like it was a
different week when it came to that kind
of stuff hey let's be careful with you
know papers that were handing out or
let's be careful with things we're
talking about in certain places and if
you're gonna have to talk about things
like if you're there in a hotel
somewhere like who knows who you know
it's always a joke it's a running joke
like hey what what person and on the
staff out here you know that the hotel
might be you know you know talking to
the Patriots it's it's like a you know
it didn't mean most the time it's it's
kind of just being facetious and you're
just making a joke of it but at the same
time it's like hey you are thinking
about that while you're there I mean
it's just
hey if they've been a part of it so I
mean it is what it is you know they're
also a tremendous organization I've had
a lot of success but they've also been
involved in some things that you know
raised they raised the antennas a little
bit on that kind of stuff Andrew
Whitworth few more minutes left okay
coach oh and Joe burrow and the rest of
the team I'm just naming just - it's
been dynamite for me to watch and I have
zero allegiance to this school does this
make you nervous you're looking for a
trapdoor or you think this is this is
gonna be it for LSU it makes me nervous
that the only thing they just played so
well that you go man I mean you know
just in general and football eventually
you would think you have your game when
when you don't and so you just keep
saying hey you know what this team's
talented enough they have the right the
right makeup they're made of the right
stuff and hopefully they can continue to
put this together for two more
performances well you know schemes you
know fits you know quarterback play you
know windows that are being hit jail
bharo is out of his skull right now what
are you seeing when you watch him play
all right special really the poise just
the command he plays with you see a
young quarterback who sure looks like he
could be a heck of a pro quarterback he
he just has a calmness to him in that
pocket and toughness I you know it's
sometimes watching him play you know I
told something today a little bit of
Rollins burger to me like he's a little
tough to get down fight sex off he is
you hearing Brady not been yeah but you
know you really think of how many times
you see me you know really avoid people
in the pocket or kind of toss a rusher
off of him and then find a way to get a
ball out I mean it's just obviously
playing in the AFC
nor that watch bin do it to us and to
many too many times thought we had him
down on the ground but you know you see
Joe doing that kind of stuff where he
just seems so calm it there's a rusher
coming free and there's really no panic
in him it's just how can I avoid this
and still keep my eyes downfield and you
know he's not dropping his eyes and
running all the time I mean you just you
see him as a guy that looks like he he
can really play the position and
understands the pocket and understands
how to play and what to do with the
football you know in coach Joe it just
seems to be pushing every button
properly we had him on I think was it
Chris the day after two days after LSU
beat Alabama and we asked him about you
know the video that came out of the
locker room of him saying a profanity in
relation to Alabama roll tide you know
that and he said we talked to the kid
and you know and you know we we he
understands that's not the sort of stuff
we get out there and I basically said
well you know a lot of people in Alabama
might think that that is exactly how you
feel about them and he laughed and then
he's just I don't care what they think I
was about to say that is exactly what he
thinks about them you know what that's
the best part about this guy I mean you
know you can't help but love him his
passion and his energy and and the truth
is like you know what we are who we are
and that's that's that's one of the
things you appreciate about his style
and what he's done and you know what the
national championships in New Orleans
this year not the last two national
championships LSU is one have been in
New Orleans where you so right around
there I'm from Louisiana as well I won a
national championship New Orleans
against Oklahoma so okay you know what
I'm feeling good about it right now and
the other national championship they won
was against our house Ohio State so hmm
we got some common teams in here and
we're going to a common place if we get
a chance to win against Oklahoma so I
feel good about it okay before I let you
go Andrew Whitworth you want to talk
about you are what you are you are
somebody who will be turning 38 on
Thursday year 14 it seems like I ask you
this every time you come here is this
your last year in the NFL you know I
think I give you the same answer every
time
you know what I'm enjoying what I do
have a still have a great passion for
the game and feel great
so as far as I go I mean I I don't see
it as being that but um you know you
never know what the future holds so I
hope I get a chance to play more
football but if not you know what we'll
figure it out well look do you do what
you need to do but I mean when you leave
here and you go up the the ramp to go on
the 105 that's right behind us you get a
perfect look at that new stadium
I mean you I imagine you're gonna want a
place now to be pretty fun to run out
that run out that tunnel the first time
they play a game in it so we'll see
hopefully I'll get an opportunity to do
it okay very good
okay cameras down Rams staff cameras
down okay well actually no you can shoot
behind-the-scenes of me wrapping up this
conversation but and then after that I'm
gonna have to see your video cards okay
and then that's just the way it Rob no
offense that's okay as long as you know
what you were informed and we weren't
filming any sideline stuff we're good I
don't think there is right Chris we're
all in the clear anything as far as I
know no too far were they shooting human
the knobs on your board they were I mean
do you understand what you do and how
you move your hands on that sound board
how it makes you unique and that perhaps
your secrets of how you move your right
and left hand and push those buttons
emmy-winning mixing so that you never
know rich link me over you're trying to
get a little let us know good luck in
Dallas and Beyond and let's stay in
touch okay let's do it
Andrew Whitworth 77 on hands true
Instagram at a Whitworth 77 on Twitter
844 204 rich number to dial we'll check
on our poll question America's
Sweetheart Pat McAfee will join us in
our number two Danny DeVito in studio
our three here on the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app